JM Levine wrote operation Gemini
it's inspired by true events and the
script Chronicles the struggle of a
desperate mother to rescue her newborn
twins from the chaos of the war in the
Ukraine please join me in welcoming JM
Jonathan to the stage
[Applause]
uh hello everybody
um
you know I'd like to say thank you to
the academy and to the members of the
nickel committee I'm humbled and shocked
by all of this
I'd also like to say what a pleasure has
been getting to know the other fellows
this year present and past and uh
sharing in their belief that this has
all been a big mistake
um my script operation Jim and I
should not exist as many of you probably
gathered from its topicality it was
written with great speed
on March 8th I was driving to pick up my
daughter from daycare the nickel late
deadline this year was May 2nd and a
story came on the radio and Kiev right
as Russia started its invasion of
Ukraine a woman gave birth to twins the
one was a surrogate for a couple in
Chicago and the couple contacted project
Dynamo to get the woman and her babies
out of the country project Dynamo picked
them up drove them 13 hours through ice
storms and checkpoints to meet the
family from Chicago on the border of
Poland
I heard this and thought this sounds
like a pretty cool movie I mean saving
babies in a war zone come on
um it felt simple it felt propulsive
felt like it would be a good read
um but I didn't really have the time or
the energy I have a four-year-old
daughter demanding day job as a
executive or production company and to
be honest
writing it felt like a waste of time
it's been over a decade writing spec
feature after respect feature after
respect feature after TV pilot after TV
pod after pitch deck after spec feature
and taking meeting after meeting after
meeting
and I just really couldn't bring myself
to do it again I was still developing
and creating things for my job and that
was fine but there was no real reason to
write another feature
um but still there was something about
this story and he kept gnawing at me so
I told my wife Marion about it I said
hey so I heard this story about this
woman who gave birth to twins during the
Russian invasion this team went into and
she said stop stop
it's too much I can't handle babies in a
war zone right now
a very uncharacteristic response from
her is this an emotional reaction just a
sentence
as a husband I felt bad didn't mean to
stress her out but as a writer my
reaction was oh
maybe there's something here
in fact I was convinced that I'd go
online a year from now and see this was
being made into a movie and I'd have the
reaction that I'm sure plenty of you in
this room have had
where you'd curse and say I had it first
writer shouts and clouds
so I went for it I spent the next seven
weeks working on working for an hour a
night maybe two if things were going
really well doing my best not to ruin a
simple idea
I finished a draft my wife was the only
person who read it gave me notes back
less than 12 hours and then I submitted
it
but one of the most striking notes
Marion gave me when she read it was you
know you are your main character in this
script you are Sam
well in the script Sam was an
electrician from New Jersey who goes to
Ukraine because he just felt a calling
to be there a calling to help and he's
an amalgamation of real selfless people
that I read about who just flocked to
the country to try to make a difference
but Sam is broken
he is there certainly to help but also
because he has nowhere else to be
he has no family he has lost himself and
doesn't see a Way Forward
running head first into a war zone and
saving these children is his way of
finding his worth and rediscovering
himself
so Marion pointed this out I had a
little revelation
I had to write this story I needed to
write this story
I had to find myself again just as Sam
had to save these twins I had to finish
the script and find a way back to myself
it reminded me why I started writing
stories in the first place because I
loved it
it was how I processed the world
with operation Gemini it was processing
being a parent covid social unrest the
world at times feeling like it's gone
crazy
I didn't write this spec script from
Fear
I was writing from inspiration and I was
writing from heart
and you know what
it makes writing that next spec script
sound like fun
but enough about what the writer thinks
our only obligation is to create
characters in the story that you care
about meh
any deeper analysis can be left to
Scholars and psychiatrists so a quick a
few quick thank yous
I'd like to thank my family and friends
for their unending support I'd like to
thank my daughter Emma for keeping me
grounded for filling my soul and for
showing me that life can and should be
silly and fun and to my wife Marion my
Leading Lady my producer my partner in
this madness thank you for obviously the
good notes but for believing in me when
I do not believe in myself
the scene you're about to hear falls in
the middle of the story
our main character Sam is having a
reflective moment that's interrupted by
a group of Ukrainian soldiers who make
fun of him for being a crazy American
who thinks he can just come in and Save
the Day
but what's really on Sam's mind is how
he has just had a falling out with his
only friend in this war a next soldier
from Spain named Alvaro and how it's
time for Sam to come clean about why he
came to Ukraine
what an honor thank you all so much
[Applause]
[Music]